- I said well, how do you,
why are you here?
And he goes I'm with my girlfriend,
we're traveling around, I met the Pope
on the subway about when I was 17.
And I'm like, you met
the Pope on a subway?
And he goes, yeah, and
you know he talked to me
about Catholicism and
had me go down and work
in the villas with Pepe and, you know,
that's how I got to know Pepe and I said,
well when did you see him last?
And he goes like four years ago,
just before he became Pope.
And I said, well, how did you end up here
you must be good pals with him.
And he goes, no no no, I was
in the general congregation
there on Wednesday
when the Pope goes
through in the Popemobile
and waves at everybody, and he gets out
of the Popemobile, sees this guy,
and he goes, I can't
remember the guy's name,
let's just say Andru,
hey, how are you?
And the guy goes, you remember me?
And he goes, of course, I got out
of the Popemobile to say hi to you.
He introduces him to his girlfriend
that he's traveling around in Europe with,
they're now married,
and the Pope goes,
Hey, do you wanna come to Mass tomorrow?
And the guy goes, sure.
And he goes, give me your phone number
He gives him his cell phone number,
he hands it to his, you know, aide,
and the guy goes, he gives him a hug,
and was like wow.
I said what happened,
he goes I sat with my cell phone,
two o'clock, three o'clock, four o'clock
nobody called, five
o'clock the phone rings,
the guys say you're friends with the Pope,
I say yeah I'm friends with the Pope.
He says show up at the gate at 6:30,
and we have no clothes
because we're traveling
through Europe, so my girlfriend's
in this red, ugly outfit
and I'm in like a sport
coat, and I said, wow
and he was the last one
in line for the picture,
and I said, what did the Pope say to you?
And he said, Francesco
goes, you crashed the party.
And he gave me a hug and I'm like,
that's the story.
I mean the guy's driving
around the Popemobile
in the middle of St. Peter's
Square and sees this guy
he hasn't seen in four years, stops,
and gives him a hug and
invites his girlfriend and him,
who are traveling in sin, to Mass,
to have Mass in the morning.
It's a pretty good story, right?
(applause)
- [Announcer] On that sinful,
outrageous note, we're gonna